come on
a California man now faces two counts of
attempted murder after firing his ghost
gun and hitting an LAPD squad car
the sixth Los Angeles Police Department
Olympic Patrol officers were driving
along the city's East Side officials say
it was then that 29 year old suspect
Jose Delgado opened fire hitting one of
the squad cars officers can be heard
calling out this shooting via radio in
this recording
his house fire
arming running eastbound on zico
Boulevard
the incident was also caught on dash
camera video as officers drove by
a recording from the rear of this squad
car shows the same moments when Delgado
allegedly opens fire after that he's
seen running off
security camera footage shows Delgado
running from police before tossing his
gun onto the side of the road the same
moments are captured on body camera
video showing officers chase after
Delgado
[Music]
control give me a perimeter please we're
gonna be a Pico and do we I need a unit
All the Way South of Pico honduri
video then shows an officer recovered
elgato's weapon
requests
[Applause]
that's the gun right yeah okay
36 also uh bfi's High we're gonna have
uh
foreign
this way but give me a full perimeter
officials later determined it was a
ghost gun meaning it was manufactured
without a serial number making it
impossible for investigators to trace a
ghost gun also means it can be purchased
without completing a background check
just minutes after Delgado ditched that
ghost gun officers caught up with him
body camera video shows this interaction
hey stop right there stop right there
stelgato he runs off before taunting the
officers come here come here bro
get down
seconds later Delgado is tased
next officers handcuffed Elgato and take
him into custody
ah
um
[Music]
I just want to make sure yes
after Delgado was taken into custody
officials determined he'd been shot
during this altercation he was taken to
the hospital and treated for his
injuries before he was cleared to be
released he was later booked into the
Los Angeles County Jail Delgado now
faces multiple charges including two
counts of attempted murder to more
counts of assault with a deadly weapon
upon a police officer and shooting into
an occupied vehicle right now the
officer-involved shooting is still under
investigation reporting for long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie